[Music]
the council recently held its March
meeting and here's a brief recap of some
of the items discussed Judge John
Brandt's Giessen was presented with a
community service award it recognises
the time and dedication he has provided
to various charities and organizations
within the Waimakariri district and
across New Zealand he was a solicitor in
renderer for 22 years and was appointed
as a judge in 2016 the council confirmed
the name of the new cycle way and
walkway currently being built between
rhaenyra and wood éand that will be
known as the regular wooden path it's
expected to be completed in the middle
of the year following the recent
successful opening of the Passchendaele
memorial path between Cairo and Ranga
and following consultation with the
community new speed limits were approved
for Li's road and Barker's Road and Kai
poi both roads will now have a speed
limit of 50 km/h reduced from the
current 80 kilometers per hour
feedback from local residents was
strongly in favor of a reduction the
next monthly council meeting will take
place on Tuesday the 3rd of April at
council chambers and Angora
[Music]